Hello.
Hello. Wait.
Oh, yes?
Oh, it's wet.
Did you spit on the carpet?
No.
It may be drool.
Really? Is it?
I'm totally kidding you.
I got you scared for a minute.
I am very scared.
I'm a very nervous man.
I like your bling. It's very nice.
It's all fake, by the way.
Is it, really?
Yes.
Well, that'll be right at home here.
This is all fake. I'm a 14-year-old girl.
Nice to meet you.
It's very nice to meet you.
Did I pronounce your name properly?
I told my best friend from high school that I was coming on your show...
...and she said, "He's so delicious." I swear she did.
Delicious?
Delicious was the word that she used.
Then I said, "He's funny."
Yeah, he's fun.
But not delicious.
Maybe delicious.
Yeah, "Delicious" was the name I used to dance under.
But that's behind me now. I'm in the big time.
Yeah, woohoo! Look at this, the great view of LA.
Are you still in Hawaii?
Yes, I do live in Hawaii, which is beautiful, beautiful.
And I'm still on the show.
Right, 'cause we keep getting people from "Lost" and then...
And then we're, right, people do get killed off quite often.